alors là du coup je suis dans la petite
forêt qui à côté du terrain vague et la
communauté soudanaise en fait se cache
ici pour essayer de pas être expulsés
par la police le matin donc qu'ils ont
essayé à récupérer quelques bâches
quelques tentes certains dorment à même
le sol alors qu'il commence à faire
froid et qui commencent à pleuvoir assez
régulièrement mais voilà ils se sont
installés un petit lieu de vie dans
cette forêt où ils essayent de survivre
tant bien que mal en attendant de passer
dans des camions qui sont juste à côté
dans le parking à côté donc voilà ils
m'ont accueilli très gentiment on
m'offrait un petit cachet que je vais
aller déguster juste maintenant
actuellement je me trouve à calais dans
le nord de la france lui un véritable
drame humain qui se déroule depuis des
années qui fait que s'amplifier en fait
il ya des milliers de réfugiés qui
tentent de rejoindre les côtes anglaises
chaque mois ils également ces réfugiés
pour la plupart d'entre eux ils ont
quitté des pays en guerre où il est en
danger de mort ils ont traversé toute
l'europe et là ils sont complètement
coincé à calais parce que ni la france
la grande-bretagne ne veut les
accueillir ils se retrouvent ici
ensemble errer sans solution ils sont
dans des camps insalubres où il ya des
hommes des femmes des enfants des
familles qui dorment à même le sol dans
la boue parfois ils ont pu te tenterait
police évacue les camps
dimanche tous les jours et donc ces
personnes mais ils sont obligés de
prendre des risques énormes pour pouvoir
rejoindre l'en
ces grillages et barbelés que vous voyez
il y en a des kilomètres et des
kilomètres partout dans la ville de
canet pour empêcher les exilés les sans
papiers de traverser d'essayer
d'attraper un camion pour partir
illégalement en grande bretagne donne un
air de ville fétiche est assez étrange
so why don't you said écosse
et
c'est
tant mieux
quant aux avoirs
bree univers we need one day
[Musique]
soler adonis lapina bête francs falaise
ceux qui n'ont pas d'argent en fait
tentent leur chance en agrippant un
camion comme les camions qui est
derrière moi c'est un parking beaucoup
de sans papiers étant de l'an chance
tous les soirs et donc ses camions ils
partent en angleterre il se met ça sur
un bateau soit elle travaille à le
tunnel sous la manche il ya un drame qui
s'est déroulé il ya quelques jours il ya
un jeune soudanais de 20 ans qui
s'appelait yasser qui est décédé qui
s'est fait écraser par un camion les six
ans de la grippe et
et là on voit que la police commence
déjà à tourner autour du terrain vague
on va voir un peu comment ça se passe la
nuit
m
[Musique]
je suis avec un groupe d'exilés sous
d'années qui habite donc dans cette
forêt à côté du parking et là ils sont
en train de faire à manger
d'une petite recette avec des oignons de
la sauce tomate du ton et voilà et
cuisiner avec un peu les moyens du bord
pour se nourrir le soir avant de tenter
sa chance
dégage à l'origine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
3 ça fait quatre ans j'ai pas vu et ça
fait combien de temps que tu es à calais
quatre mois
ici l'appli paul un policier things we
came to mix la poule nous sommes des
glaces
la
ddjs can à 0
bon bah il est bientôt minuit les gars
vont aller se coucher un peu pro se
reposer et ils vont tenter leur chance
avec les camions vers 5 heures du matin
du coup en fait ils partent par petits
groupes à différentes heures et
s'échangent des informations pour sa
part si la police est dans le coin ou
pas et donc voilà ils vont partir dans
des chemins différents sur des parkings
à différents endroits aussi en plus de
celui d'en face en fonction du mouvement
de la police
allait rentrer en l'église saint pierre
où il ya trois personnes comme ça avait
une grève de la faim devant un prêtre
jésuite pour dénoncer des traitements
qui sont infligées aux exilés alors on
va les voir un peu comment ça se passe
pour eux c'est leur quatrième jour de
grève de la faim
je trouve ça étrange de mettre en place
des arrêtés anti distribution qui font
que même des calaisiens hors
associations des calaisiens qui aimerait
donner de la nourriture à des personnes
exilées n'ont pas le droit et si elles
le font alors une amende
à la solidarité en fait c'est quoi ce
pays
ludovic et moi même on entame une grève
de la faim ici sur le terrain la
politique vis-à-vis des migrants se
durcit le harcèlement s'amplifie la
volonté de ne leur laisser aucun répit
vous prend des dimensions cadets
jusqu'ici d'où nous notre volonté de
dire ça suffit voilà roux n'en peut plus
de supporter ça parce qu'effectivement
c'est en france en 2021 et que sur ce
graphe et on en finirait presque à
s'habituer à ce qui est bien quelque
chose inadmissible intolérable et qui
est une véritable horreur des gens
étaient un peu paralysés devant le dsq
lourdingue
marine le pen
tout ce qui se passe il a calé et puis
il fallait le déclic pour que ça
réagisse dans mon avis et c'est le
déclic pour
attendez j'ai travaillé pendant trente
cinq ans avec les arrivées ici nous fait
des émules chez moi comme j'ai des
exilés chez moi maintenant mais
oui c'est ça mais je veux dire pour moi
je pose pas les uns et les autres dans
tous les cas il ya quelque chose qui
marche pas donc on leur enlève les
tentes et sans oublier de coucher par
terre sous la pluie et dans le froid
dans l'humidité c'est ça doit trouver le
point ce tueur à la servitude du mur
dans quelles conditions au moment où il
ya le gel c'est à dire quand il ya le
plan grand froid seulement mais ici à
calais jeudi à vivre dehors avec l'appui
quand ça tombe etc c'est incroyable on a
un état qui par le d'accueil médias qui
appelait qui pratiquent pas l'accueil
vous allez en cause s'est fortement ses
débuts
fulgurants africain
il ya même des arguments qui sont dans
la conversation vous venez d'entendre le
prêtre philippe et ses paroissiens là
elle est très symbolique est très
récurrentes en fait il ya une grosse
division au sein de la population de
calais il ya une part de la population
qui pour l'accueil des réfugiés l'autre
qui est complètement contre est
d'ailleurs le prince philippe a reçu des
menaces sur son téléphone portable et et
des lettres anonymes qui ont été déposés
dans l'église il n'y a pas longtemps oui
au départ la réaction est née elle
négative
avec les arguments
aussi aurait un temps souvent pourquoi
faire attention aux exilés pas aux sans
abri
alors maintenant c'est que quand vous
laisse ou de l'année est en train d'être
évacué par la police alors je vais les
voir un peu
d'habitude il ne l'est pas les
journalistes rentrée pour filmer de
pimenter ce qui s'y passe pendant
l'évacuation a évoqué d'autres les deux
christophe
attaquer les problèmes
bon la police vient juste de partir et
juste à ce moment là elle commence à
pleuvoir
donc les exilés là vont revenir dans
leur petite forêt pour réinstaller leur
campement comme ils peuvent voilà c'est
comme ça quasiment tous les jours
mais voilà ils ont vraiment un bon leur
chante toutes les tentes et les matelas
qu'ils ont réussi à sauver avant que la
police n'arrive pas ce qu'ils ont eu
quelques informations d'associations et
donc c'était un peu au courant que la
police allait venir ils ont réussi à
sauver quelques affaires mais pas tous
là où d'oeil au film bad cetelem battre
dans le forage police
les fournisseurs
doivent
d'abord que nous à autre
en fait la grande bretagne elle est
juste là à 30 kilomètres on peut la voir
et l'autre côté de la manche beaucoup
beaucoup
et pas
avant de petitcodiac pour essayer de
rejoindre
les côtes anglaises
ces bateaux ils sont à traiter à part
des par des passeurs la place elle coûte
entre 2 et 3000 euros donc c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent alors il ya
beaucoup d chacun il ya beaucoup
zodiac qui s'échouent à quelques
centaines de mètres de là et si beaucoup
l'intervention policière un nombre
beaucoup se sont fait attraper par la
police et ni sur les côtes françaises
pendant est un but de mayence my boat is
a [ __ ]
iphoto wallis
les vasques ce jeune homme de 25 ans on
va essayer ce soit de passer par la mer
ça fait plusieurs mois qu'ils essayent
de passer avec les camions de monter à
bord d'un camion sans succès et l'est la
russie à prendre contact avec un passeur
qui le donnaient rendez vous ce soir là
façon ça que la paroisse de prendre
grand-chose jordan tout petit sac avec
quelques affaires et il va partir
[Applaudissements]
maroni
bah ouais
dès que
bon ça y vient de partir pour rejoindre
les autres passagers et ensuite le
passeur j'avoue je suis un peu inquiète
pour lui j'espère qu'il ya au moins des
jets de sauvetage à bord ils vont partir
aux mamans vers 2 3 heures du matin là
je peux pas du tout les suivre les
passeurs veut pas du tout en train de
parler de cas mais en général
[Musique]
alors là j'ai rejoint les membres de
l'association utopia 56 qui font des
maraudes sur la plage pour voir s'il n'y
a pas des réfugiés quand j'ai besoin des
deux pour être potentiellement fait
naufrage qui n'auraient pas réussi à
monter à bord des bateaux je les suivre
ce soir pour voir un peu comment ça se
passe
donc j'en sois tu en vois pas grand
chose
il a peu près 5 heures du matin allez il
fait très froid et d'affaires de 3
degrés maximum on est dans une dune à
une trentaine quarantaine de kilomètres
de calais ici à beaucoup beaucoup de
végétation c'est très très très très
grand donc c'est facile pour les
réfugiés de se cacher le service de
police c'est quand même sacrément
flippant
[Musique]
du coup
ça peut être des personnes qui qui vont
tenter de rejoindre l'angleterre
pour intervenir
on va pas les éclairer parce qu'ils sont
déjà complètement effrayé en général ils
ont très très peur de la mer et
risquerait de croire que c'est la police
donc on veut pas qui dit panique qui se
précipitent dans l'eau il savait ce que
ray de d'être catastrophique
ag
impression qu'un bateau vienne
donc j'ai reçu un message de mohammad un
le jeune soudanais de 25 ans qui devait
passer cette nuit par bateau
j'avais un petit peu espoir de le
retrouver ici je vous avoue mais
malheureusement il m'a envoyé un message
comme quoi il s'était fait planter par
le passeur donc lui les passagers sont
toujours en attente dans un coin de la
ville mais a priori lui va pas passer ce
soir ça va pas être possible
les informations qu'on a eue il ya deux
bateaux qui seraient partis samedi
serait parti
y a personne qui a
d'être restée sur la côte sur les plages
personne qui a besoin notre aide directe
et donc là l'idée ça va être
et voir à la gare
monsieur sur la route voir s'il ya des
personnes qui ont essayé oui
pas réussi à y arriver potentiellement
qui sont mouillés ou
un peu de support
alam
eh
oui
coach
e
mais son prix by veuve
alors je te croiser une famille
irakienne a une petite idée et des
enfants en bas âge je pense y en a ils
n'ont pas plus de six ans ils ont essayé
de passer cette nuit mais leur moteur et
tombe en panne du prix ils ont dépensé
tout leur argent ils n'ont plus rien et
ils sont frigorifiés
la
rue de dunkerque de commerce de bosses
28 août à nantes duensing des notes
comme monsieur et malheureusement nous
on a très peu de pouvoir quoi là il
souhaiterait être réorientés par exemple
vers des centres d'hébergement donc ils
sont prêts à aller dans les centres
d'hébergement mais malheureusement les
bus passent trop tôt donc
ils pourront pas y accéder avant demain
est donc là dans les faits on n'a aucune
solution à proposer à tous tous ces
jeunes et tous ces adultes quoi
ah ouais
sur le port de boulogne il ya des
sauveteurs en mer pour récupérer 6 ou
d'année apparemment si mineur qui
étaient à bord de l'embarcation
ils viennent d'être ramenés sur le port
là et les pompiers les prennent en
charge apparemment ça va pas très bien
si les filles pour dire quatre de 16 ans
et 17 ans
on en a deux qui sont en hypothermie qui
sont au moins 34 degrés donc le
diagnostic vital n'est pas engagé il
faut prendre si toutefois
ils m'ont tous dirigés dans l'hôpital de
bruyn 100 m alors ils ont été vues vers
6h30 par un témoin qui a alerté le cross
ils ont été récupérés par la marine
nationale vers 8h30 à 2 nautiques de la
côte d'après la marine nationale il
était en mer depuis 14 30 ce matin quand
même ou alors donc nous on va récupérer
les mineurs on va leur donner à manger
puis on va appeler france-eire d'asile
comme verts au caire c'est la procédure
qu'on fait
[Musique]
voilà j'espère qu'ils avaient apprécié
ce reportage et que vous avez appris des
choses je voulais vous faire une petite
image l'église saint pierre avant de
partir de calais ils sont à leur
septième jour de grève de la faim
[Musique]